this is monumental hello and welcome to
Playstation grenade were you unhappy
with the PS Plus offerings for this
month well take another look
because at the last moment Pro Evolution
Soccer 2019 has been replaced with two
great games in one package Detroit
become human and heavy rain
Detroit become human is only just one
year old and that present remains a
PlayStation exclusive although not for
much longer
we take control of three androids and
experience the story of technology's
role in futuristic life the androids
want to be treated as equals but society
is not ready for that yet the game plays
more like an interactive movie with
elements of point-and-click sleuthing -
but the power of the storytelling cannot
be understated this to me is a
masterpiece each scenario can play out
many different ways making your
playthrough completely different from
your mate Dave's so take control of a
police investigator trying to track down
a potential child killer or housekeeping
droid who is trying to save a child or
even a caretaker who could lead a
revolution depending on how you play
they try to become human received many
high scores evening out at about eight
out of ten this is an excellent game so
please try it and that's not it part of
the deluxe edition of Detroit become
human we will also get to download heavy
rain heavy rain is very similar from
Detroit but this time you'll be tracking
down the origami killer with every
action potentially causing the death of
a character but here's the best bit in
almost all scenarios the story continues
regardless no retries if you fail you
may miss a piece of evidence which could
likely change the story's outcome both
of these games have stellar voice acting
and awesome storytelling so over to you
are you happy with this change do you
think our dislike of the first PS Plus
offerings have caused this change I'd
love to know your thoughts I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade get your ass into
gear and download the PS + games for the
month I'll see you next time
[Music]